I'm going to give you an astounding
result it's down there an astounding
result so I was going to write down a
little some I'm just going to see what
what answer it gives one plus two plus
three plus four plus du duta-de and I
include all the natural numbers so all
the way up to infinity so what do you
reckon the answer to this is Brady well
I would say it would go do tend towards
infinity yeah that makes sense doesn't
it the answer to this song is remarkably
-12 it's amazing I mean I first saw this
result when I started letting a bit a
string theory and what's even more
bizarre is that this result is used in
many areas of physics this is a very
well string theory textbook by
geopolitics key as you can see it's sort
of quite early on page 22 we have this
statement here which is that there's
some of all this is basically saying
that sum of all the integers or the
natural numbers all the way up to
infinity is minus a12 all right so we're
going to prove now without getting our
knickers in a twist with Riemann zeta
functions we're going to prove quite a
simple way why the sum of all the
natural numbers is indeed minus a12 so
to do that we're going to have to do
this in a number of steps we're going to
look at a few different songs the first
song that I want to look at I'm going to
call it s1 and it's 1 minus 1 plus 1
minus 1 plus 1 minus 1 and so on that's
the first thing I want to look at in
principle the second sum I'm going to
look at is 1 minus 2 plus 3 minus 4 and
so on
carry on in that process all the way up
and the third one is of course going to
be our r1 that we're really interested
in which is 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 to do
so up so we're going to evaluate all
these three different songs now the
first one is really easy to evaluate we
need to attach a number now clearly what
is the answer this now you take you take
you stop this at any point okay if you
stop it at an odd point you're going to
get the answer 1 you stop it as an even
point at an even point you'll get the
answer 0 clearly that's obvious right so
what number are we going to
to this infinite sum do we stop it and
eat in an odd or an even point we don't
know so we take the average of the two
so the answers are huh there are other
ways to prove that this sum is a half by
the way which we can do if you want but
no know there'll be a link don't be a
link there because we've done it before
okay could see the link there okay so so
this is a heart but I think intuitively
that's the easiest way to see it that
you either get 0 or 1 and therefore you
just take the average so this is the
natural number to it attach this sum but
once we know this we're laughing okay
because from this we we can it we can
achieve everything that we want to
achieve the next step is to find out
what this sum is so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take two copies of this
s2 okay so I'm going to add it to itself
so two times s2 is equal to well let me
just write it out so I'm going to write
it out twice one minus two plus three
minus four little innit so on and then
I'm going to add to it itself but I'm
going to shift it along a little bit so
that's plus 1 minus 2 plus 3 minus 4 and
so on
ok I've just taken two copies and added
them to get it but I've done it in a
particularly nice way and I just push
this one along slightly on the bottom so
now you see what you get you take this
one and this this and this and I get 1
so 1 plus nothing is 1 minus 2 plus 1
minus 1 3 minus 2 is 1 minus 4 plus 3 is
minus 1 to the digit and so on and I'm
going to keep getting this pattern so
hang on a minute I've just got back to
something I started with which I know
the answer to so half okay so therefore
I know this sum now so I just divide
through by these two and I get 1/4 so
now I know that this song this second
song with some where the the signs
alternate is actually equal to 1/4 so
this is my second remarkable result now
I have everything I need to prove this
crazy madness it's filing right okay so
let's do it I'm going to take this one
and I'm going to subtract this one okay
so I'm going to subtract s 2 from s
let's write American ok so I'm going to
write our s first which is 1 plus 2 Plus
3 plus 4
there's five and set one okay and I'm
going to subtract s2 so that's - okay
let me just put a bracket in now because
I'm going to minus all of this one minus
two plus three minus four and so on
okay okay one minus one what's that
you're a zero yeah exactly so I get
nothing from that bit 2 minus minus 2 is
okay 3 minus 3 0 4 minus minus 4 is 8
and so on and the next one I'm going to
get from the 5 so I get nothing from the
sixes I get 12 and so on to do it and it
precedes in that way
and now you can see we're almost there
now alright because look what I've got
here I've got 4 plus 8 plus 12 but I
take a factor of 4 out it's 4 times 1
plus 2 Plus 3 to do it ok it's my son
that I wanted so now I've got a formula
for Mike so this is just 4 times s which
is my son now I just solve this equation
right because I know what s 2 is so I
have now the expression that s - Clara s
2 is s 2 s 1/4 is equal to 4 s okay I
take s from either side so I get minus
1/4 is equal to 3s which implies s
equals minus 12 the daddy of reasoning
that's amazing a little bit summation
either boy Charlie if I got a calculator
out and wrote 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4
plus 5 and I sit here until the end of
everything and then press equals would I
get - I mean the end of everything you
can't do it to the end of everything can
you so see the point is I know this
looks like a bit of a mathematical
hocus-pocus sort of thing but it
actually the truth it's not and I tell
you why we know it's not we don't know
you think I got about physics too much
but we know it's not because of physics
because these kinds of Psalms appear in
physics and in physics we don't get
infinite answers it's amazing it's
amazing and it's just do you know I was
trying to come up with it and
give reason for this and I just could be
honest this you have to do the
mathematical hocus pocus really to see
it and then you just have to believe
that you're not measuring physical
infinities in nature and then those two
together I think give you
confidence in this result but it is
clearly counterintuitive in its
counterintuitive because you know
intuitively you just want to stop the
sequence and the minute you stop the
sequence then all your intuitions for
this result goes out the window so if I
do 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5 and I
go up to a googolplex you'll get a big
number yeah you won't get anything like
matters at 12 you have to get infinity
Brady it's negative I've added all these
positive numbers together up to infinity
and I've got minus a 12 but it does
player at play a role in lots of
different things does that the number 12
and and it's so for example as I said
the the calculations of the critical
dimension in string theory that 26
dimensions comes from this calculation